On paper, chemistry looks like little Cs,
Hs, and Os,... flat… simple… but just
like a map versus a globe, that's just a representation:
not only are molecules three-dimensional,
they're "handed"
Hey handymen and handywomen, Trace here on
DNews today.
Scientists find incredible things in space
all the time.
It's space, it's fantastic, but this find
is a doozy.
Using sensitive radio telescopes, astronomers
found a complex organic molecule in interstellar
space.
The molecule is propylene oxide and it was
found in a star-forming region near the centre
of our Milky Way galaxy.
But it gets better, this discovery might show
that life on Earth is not as unique as we
may have thought.
Propylene oxide is what’s known as a handed
molecule.
Handed, in this case, doesn’t mean being
right or left handed like we’re used to
it meaning, but hands are a good way to illustrate
what it does mean.
Handed in this case means two molecules are
mirror images, they're similar, but flipped,
they're asymmetrical!
If you put your hands side by side, they mirror
each other, but put one on top of the other
and you’ll find they aren’t superimposable.
And this is a super exciting find for scientists
because molecules on Earth are just like this
too!
Lemme explain.
Handedness is a chemical property called chirality.
And chirality matters because the building
blocks of life are chiral.
For example: DNA only twists in a right-handed
screw… and only uses right-handed molecules
of the sugar ribose, but it also uses only
left-handed amino acids.
Basically, different parts life evolved to
favour one “hand” over another, and scientists
have no idea why.
Every living thing has somehow determined
it will use one, and only one of the chiral
molecules available in nature.
And even though they exist, they're super
curious, because chiral molecules "have the
same melting, boiling, and freezing points,"
and even produce the same spectra when they
emit light.
But, even though they behave the same way,
they're not the same.
Like a glove only fits on one hand, molecules
have to fit together in a very specific way,
and, for some reason, life evolved so only
certain hands fit with each other.
It's confusing, and crazy, but that's how
nature works!
Why?
We don't know!
A paper in Nature, posits asymmetrical molecules
may have evolved, because radioactive decay
destroys left-handed molecules more quickly,
leaving only right-handed ones.
If this was also the case early in life's
evolution, it could explain why DNA is mostly
right-handed.
Scientists also know that molecules large
enough with an electrical charge will find
their like type to bind with, meaning this
is among their chemical properties.
But still, the scientists admit that "we may
never know" exactly why this happens.
What we do know is this chirality is present
on Earth, and has been found in our solar
system as well, on both meteorites and in
comets.
Of course, since we know life exists here…
we live here… it makes sense that we'd find
chiral molecules.
Finding a chiral molecule in interstellar
space on the other hand (pun intended), means
chirality didn’t spring up on Earth.
It makes it even more awesome.
And that's exactly what the scientists found.
So, if these chiral molecules existed in the
cloud of gas and dust that became our solar
system, they could have reached Earth via
a meteorite or comet.
Which could help explain how life first formed
on Earth.
And finding chiral molecules in interstellar
space has a similar implication: because these
molecules exist here, and now we know they
exist out there, that could mean, that organic
molecules as we know them could come together
on ANOTHER PLANET, or perhaps they already
have…
And as you might imagine: more research is
needed.
Because they can't tell handedness from this
far away, scientists can’t tell yet which
handed version of propylene oxide they’ve
found…
Follow-up observations will use polarized
light to see if one version of the molecule
dominates space.
Let's give them a hand, eh?
This isn't the only crazy thing found in space
lately, Atomic Oxygen was found on Mars!
And it sounds like some kind of Simpsonian
superhero, but it's not.
Watch this video to find out what it is!
Up and At Dem!
Does stuff like this blow your mind?!
It totally blew mine.
If you have any other crazy science you want
to know more about…